no problem there we go you're recording
all right okay thanks gentlemen i
greatly appreciate that thank you thank
you
okay thank you for your time i know
you're a very busy lady and i know it's
the end of the week so i greatly
appreciate your time
you're welcome nice to meet you nice to
meet you as well it's kirsten so thanks
for your time
and um i know you got stuff lined up so
i won't keep you too long but
i did want to know dr biden what was
your takeaway after talking to
members of our local union you know i
was uh i was heartbroken actually i mean
here
are you know workers who have to choose
between
going to work and their health and as
you heard
you know they've had uh the virus and
their families have had the virus
and the you know the one mom said or the
one woman said she felt so guilty
because she felt that
she had passed it on to her husband and
to her niece
and um there's a lot of anxiety out
there and i think that's what i'm seeing
and that's what i'm hearing as i travel
virtually or literally across this
country
you know there's so much chaos and
confusion
and anxiety in donald trump's america
and i feel that if my husband were
president at this moment
right today there wouldn't be all this
there would already be a strategy and a
plan in place
and um and people wouldn't it didn't
have to be this way
it just did not have to be this way uh
dr biden um under a biden
harris leadership um what do you think
could transpire for those in our state
you know we so rely on the hospitality
industry
and tourism of course all our
conventions have been cancelled
um what would what assistance could
could come our way that you would like
to get across
well you know we're uh we have to
do this all safely i mean
that's what it's going to take and you
know we just
really have to get this virus under
control
and uh once that once we get the virus
under control then we can start to you
know
live life as as we used to as normal
and the new normal actually but it all
depends on getting the virus under
control
you know we've heard different things we
hear oh there could be enough
um to start at the beginning of november
and then dr
fauciou here he says maybe the second
quarter of next year
um what do you believe will be the
actual case
you know i i believe we have to listen
to the doctors and the scientists
and um and when they say it's
safe to reopen that's when we're gonna
reopen so that's
that's what it's gonna take you know we
believe in the science
and not the politics
you've spent the last couple of weeks
touring across the nation with back to
school time
uh we started almost a month ago ccsd
is the fifth largest school district in
the nation and we're all doing virtual
aside from private schooling across
um the area um what's your advice for
for parents and teachers and those doing
distance learning and also dr biden
um what are your hopes for when the kids
will be able to return to the classroom
well my advice is and you know what i
take away from this is it's so hard you
know it's so hard
for the kids because they want to be in
school it's so hard for
educators like me because i want to be
in my classroom
and heck it's so hard for the parents
who are trying to work
and then trying to help their kids with
schoolwork and be creative
and trying to do it all but you know we
you know i continue to say we must
listen to the doctors
who then tell us when it's safe to go
back
so that's that's really our only choice
is to because don't we all i mean our
first
priority has to be the health and safety
of america's children
and that has to be our priority
and um circling back dr biden to um
jobs and hospitality and tourism for uh
southern nevada and of course northern
nevada as well
obviously our state wants to move
forward we just had a mandate where now
the bars can finally open
first thing monday morning so that's
progress
uh under a biden harris uh leadership
role
what do you feel the next step would be
to helping um
the economy well we have to make sure
you know job joe has his build back
better and he's focusing
really on small businesses and getting
people back to work
i mean this is all about jobs and
um joe wants to do that you know through
rebuilding the infrastructure and
getting small businesses up
you know up and working again and just
like those the women that we just heard
from in the hospitality
we have to get things going but first
and foremost we can't do any of that
until we get the pandemic under control
one more quick one okay any last words
you'd like to offer dr biden
kirsten i hope that everybody that is
you know is
uh your viewers uh get out there and
vote
and i hope that they you know go to
iwillvote.com to find out
you know where their registration is and
and the process for voting
and then um and then i want voters to
think about
the america we're living in now and how
chaotic it is and how confusing
and joe biden will be a strong
steady leader who understands what
americans are going through
and that's the difference thank you so
much for your time today we greatly
appreciate it and um thank you dr biden
and thank you to you michael
for facilitating of course of course
thank you
have a great friday and be safe yeah
youtube
thank you bye-bye
stop recording